there was a school board meeting in
cherokee county georgia
where a mother stood up she was irate
because of the materials that were being
handed out to students in this school
and so she decided she said look you all
think it's fine for the kids to be
reading this obscene material let me
just read you some of this material and
the school board
ruled her out of order for reading
material that should not be heard
by anyone in the audience
exactly what
there are children watching you can't
read that stuff yeah that's the point
guys i'm reading the material that you
are requiring our students to read and
then i'm reading it back to you and
you're saying don't read it back to me
the students might be listening
i love i love the absolute obliviousness
from this school board and the mother
she she can't contain herself anymore
she says are you do you hear yourselves
do you hear yourselves if material is
too obscene to be read at a meeting of
the school board
which is 99
or more
for adults then the material is too
obscene to be read
to
the kids
to the children and the school board
members don't seem to process this
because the school board members aren't
really making the curriculum right the
curriculum is being created by radicals
and it is being pushed into the schools
by activists and then the school board
and the administrators and often even
the teachers really don't know anything
about it they don't know how to fight
back i bet those school board members
are just as shocked
as
as anyone to hear that that kind of
material is in the schools that's how
effective the left has been at taking
over our education system
that's how backwards everything has
gotten
it
there is no
neutrality here okay there is no
fairness we talk about we see it in in
ukraine right now banning all the
opposition parties
that's not fair that's not liberalism
that's not democracy there's no
neutrality there you see in a lot of
other worst regimes around the world
banning their opposition parties i think
the breaking news just came through that
vladimir putin just sentenced the main
opposition leader in russia who's not
even all that popular sentenced him to
another nine years in prison
but it's not just in those really bad
far away places that you see that you
see that in america too you see child
pornographers getting off the hook and
you see january 6 people going to prison
for 20 years you see blm people throwing
molotov cocktails at federal buildings
and they get a little slap on the wrist
if that
usually they just get released without
any question
and then you see conservatives being
punished you see
you see the clintons
the bidens making a boatload of money
through corruption not just in america
but overseas as well taking money and
bribes from some of the worst people in
the world and then
donald trump without any crime that i
can actually see the left point to they
they go in they bring in the southern
district of new york they try to get
this guy they try to prove
there's not
any perfect neutrality here okay we are
living in a real political regime that
really does have limits and and the
limits are moving very very far to the
left and if you are outside of those
limits the ruling class
is going to come for you right now go to
priceline.com since 1998 priceline has
been the best way for travelers to book
the trip they want at the price they can
afford priceline saves consumers more
than 1 billion dollars every year so
that their customers never have to miss
the moments that matter with priceline
you can save up to sixty percent on your
favorite hotels and you can also get
exclusive deals on rental cars and
flights when you save more you can do
more get more wow this view is
incredible more
another round of room service please
more
booyah i'm extending my vacation sorry
boss sorry ben
there are a few things that feel as good
as knowing that you saved money with the
discounts priceline offers you get that
feeling a lot because when you save more
you can enjoy more and do more at
priceline every trip is a big deal
priceline knows that every trip is a big
deal so when you're ready to book your
next one check out priceline.com for the
easiest way to get more wow more more
booyah just to name
a few out of it
did you like that clip i hope you did
i'm glad you did ring the bell subscribe
get the notifications go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show if
you would be so kind and you can head on
over right now to dailywire.com go check
out fouchy
unmasked this is my three-part
docu-series on fauci really never seen
before unprecedented stuff in this
series it's doing really really well so
we appreciate everyone who's watched it
go check that out today dailywire.com
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you